the 2024 situation is heating up and
Nikki Haley is now being sort of
pre-announced that she is going to make
an announcement uh Trump was asked I
think this is from yesterday Trump was
asked about Nikki Haley and Ron DeSantis
here's what he had to say Nikki Haley
called me the other day to talk to me
and talk to her for a little while but I
said look you know go buy your heart if
you want to run she's publicly stated I
would run against
my president he was a great president
Florida was actually closed for a great
moment I remember he closed the beaches
and everything else here you know
they're trying to rewrite histories okay
so some of this is just political
jockeying it is true that Nikki Haley
said she wasn't going to run against
Trump she did actually say that at one
point but it sounds like she is gonna uh
run so he is ever he's entitled to say
that but he's been trying one of the
things that you're seeing over the last
48 hours or so is the Trump and the
Trump surrogates are really trying to
make it seem like somehow uh DeSantis
was really for lockdowns and and really
for masks and all of this stuff and it's
like DeSantis actually picked up on it
very quickly and was trying to open up
extremely quickly so when Trump says
that about the beaches and everything
else he might be forgetting Donald Trump
from about two years ago
as many schools and school districts are
closing across the country Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has not ruled out
uh closing for opening out schools in
May
um saying that many kids are not
vulnerable to this disease do you agree
with that assessment and do you believe
that schools would recommend that
schools open up and to those states that
have well I have a lot of confidence in
Ron DeSantis a lot of faith in Ron
DeSantis to make the right decision he's
doing a great job as Governor Ron
DeSantis I had read where he's thinking
about opening up the schools earlier
than the date the end of the month uh
I'd have to look at the numbers but
again you know I liked
so again if you're a trump person and
you're watching this right the guy that
I voted for I just think this is a
losing strategy DeSantis has become the
the figurehead for fighting covid we are
we are having this policy now he has
this group of people including including
Brett Weinstein and Jay bhattacharya
from Stanford where we are going to look
into vaccine injuries like we've done
more here in Florida on the to stop the
covid madness than anywhere else also
everybody gets a little leash in the
first two months of covid including
Donald Trump by the way I also give
Donald Trump a lot of credit because
Donald Trump from the beginning did not
want to do a federal top-down policy on
covet he was pushing it all to the
States but then and nobody's perfect
when states started opening up Trump did
actually push back you may remember this
this is in April of 2020 from Reuters
U.S president Donald Trump on Wednesday
said he's strong only disagrees with
George's aggressive push to reopen its
economy in the midst of the novel
coronavirus pandemic saying it's just
too soon to lift some restrictions
Georgia Governor Brian Kemper Republican
and Trump Ally is allowing businesses
such as beauty salons tattoo parlors and
bowling alleys to reopen as soon as
Friday Trump said Georgia is not
adhering to federal guidelines for
states to restart their economies okay
so I'm just trying to give you a little
context because what do I always do on
this show we try to go to old clips so
we don't rewrite history constantly
because if you're rewriting history
constantly you will not get to a future
that is sane
foreign
[Music]